foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday November 10th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
Mastodon a decentralized microblogging
site has been blowing up in popularity
since Elon Musk completed his purchase
of Twitter so what's it like to use the
Twitter alternative and what makes
Mastodon so appealing our senior
personal Tech columnist Joanna Stern has
been giving it a go and she's here to
tell us all about it hi Joanna thanks
for coming on the show anytime so if
people are switching from Twitter to
Mastodon I mean how familiar will
Mastodon seem to people who do use
Twitter
eventually really simple but there's a
big area from getting from signing up to
figuring this out that is really
complicated I like to say it's harder to
explain than to my child why he can't
have Sour Patch Kids for every meal I
mean it's like some of it just seems
impossible but you can get through it
all and when you do get through it all
you'll have an experience that's similar
to Twitter
so it's like a a micro blogging platform
as well with where I'll have like a
username and be able to write you know
whatever I want to the world yeah so to
understand it you have to take a step
back and really what this is is
something called decentralized social
media or Federated social media as some
are calling it and so instead of one big
Tech Giant like meta with Facebook and
Instagram or Twitter with Elon Musk this
type of social network is distributed
and so the idea is is that anyone can
really run parts of this social network
and it's operated by different servers
and all of these different servers make
up the bigger social network and I know
it's starting to sound confusing but
what's nice about this is that it isn't
in the hands of one Central person and
that means that users and the people who
are running these servers can make up
the rules and they make sure sure things
are running smoothly okay so if it's not
run by one big company or one you know
individual like Elon Musk what does that
mean for people who are signing up for
Mastodon what will it mean for using the
platform yes so signing up for the
platform is definitely more complicated
than signing up for a Twitter account or
a Facebook account
you have to first sign up for a server
because as I mentioned this is all about
different servers working together and
talking to each other for this bigger
social media platform which is called
Mastodon so all these servers they make
up the Mastodon platform so when you
first sign up you select a server and
then you select a username and similar
to email you kind of get an address
together right so my server that I
signed up for last week is
mastodon.world and my username is Joanna
Stern and so that makes my whole address
Joanna Stern at mastodon.world
and so that server is where my
information my profile my posts my
database of followers and the people I
follow that's all housed on that
mastodon.world server okay so how do you
go about picking a server is there a
method to this
yeah so and that's really the hardest
part of the sign up process is picking
this server I mean first for normal
people they're like why do I need to
pick a server what is this say I'm not
an I.T consultant right so first you're
like gotta understand what this thing is
second you want to pick a server that
makes sense and so one of the ways that
the servers are sort of classified is
based on different interests you'll see
some organized by artists or music and
different interests lgbtq journalists
Etc I want to say something though that
is very important here it doesn't matter
what server you're on you can talk to
any person on any server so even though
I'm on mastodon.world and say Zoe you
are on
macedon.social I would still be able to
see your posts if I followed you and you
would still be able to see my posts if
you followed me you know you might pick
a server you said because you have a
group or Community but you know who are
the people behind them if they're not
say a company and how do you know you
can trust them with your information
yeah so this was the biggest question I
set out to find out with this piece
because I signed up for this
mastodon.world server and I started
understanding how this service works
right okay some private server owned by
somebody is housing this information and
happens to be some of my personal
information right it's got my profile
it's got a photo of me it's got my posts
even got direct messages that I'm
putting on the server so I decided to
get in touch with the person who runs
This Server and he happens to live in
the Netherlands and he decided to start
doing this as a hobby a couple of years
ago and so I got in touch with him and I
asked him okay what happens if your
server goes down he says well if my
server goes down you know yeah you would
lose everything but I've got a backup
for my server I said okay well what
about the messages that I'm sending on
direct messages can you see them he's
like well I could see them if I wanted
to if I went into gigabytes of data but
I don't want to and I don't plan to do
that unless there's some real extreme
circumstance to do that
so the conversation really to me was
about how much trust we're putting into
these people that operate the servers
and truthfully that's the case for any
social media platform you know the fact
that Mastodon is decentralized and
that's where so many people are headed
doesn't tell us anything you know sort
of overall about what individuals are
looking for when they go on social media
I think right now there is definitely a
group of people who have been on Twitter
for a long time and now are seeing the
service really disrupted by Elon Musk
For Better or For Worse we don't know
yet but there are those that are feeling
right now like this is not the place
that I came to 10 years ago when I was
first starting to use Twitter or social
media and those people might be longing
for something else I definitely know
that you know having been on Mastodon
over the last couple of days there is a
different sense of community there's a
different sense of people actually just
wanting to talk with each other and find
information versus Twitter right now
which is really just riled up in the new
ownership and lots of talk about the
principles of free speech and blue check
marks all right that's our senior
personal Tech columnist Joanna Stern
Joanna thanks for explaining this for us
anytime
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
head over to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]